i first went over there in october
of 2001 because i was a working
journalist and
you know that was my job so i've sort of
paid attention to afghanistan for 20
years not not as deeply as i thought i
was however because we learn all these
things like is that really was that
really happening the president of
afghanistan
left the country without telling anyone
and some of his aides who were at lunch
got back to the office and he was gone
he was on a flight to tajikistan with
tens of millions of us currency
how did that happen who was this guy
turns out we installed as the president
of afghanistan a professor from johns
hopkins
who like is the last person i mean it
just tells you everything about our
ruling class which is they only
talk to
believe trust promote people exactly
like
them the afghanistan stuff obviously i
have to ask you a little bit about that
because i'm just catching up on it
literally in the last 24 hours um it's
sort of from my perspective impossible
to tell exactly what happened from from
a media perspective because it seems
like they really are trying to figure
out a way not to blame the
administration but this thing seems
like as bad a bungling as
could it could it have been worse at
this point like what could have made
this worse this exit and now everything
that's happening i don't i can't see it
and i say that as someone who was
passionately
passionately in favor of withdrawing
troops because i i didn't see the point
no one could ever explain what the
mission was and that's just a violation
of my most basic rule of life which is
know why you're doing something you know
what i mean yeah especially if people
are dying and you're spending trillions
to do it what is it and no one can
answer so i was totally for pulling out
but to
in order of severity leave american
citizens behind
move
tens of thousands
of unvetted afghans who did not work for
the us military who aren't our allies
whose identities we don't know into
suburban america
and then three to leave behind 90
billion dollars worth of military
equipment an entire air force 360 000
automatic battle rifles heavy machine
guns blackhawks fixed wing i mean it
it's the taliban now control the best
armed military of its size in the world
it's unimaginable it's
unbelievable and then then you start
learning and i felt i was pretty well
versed on afghan i mean i first went
over there in october
of 2001 because i was a working
journalist and
you know that was my job so i've sort of
paid attention to afghanistan for 20
years not not as deeply as i thought i
was however because we learned all these
things was like is that really was that
really happening the president of
afghanistan
left the country without telling anyone
some of his aides who were at lunch got
back to the office and he was gone he
was on a flight to tajikistan with tens
of millions of us currency
how did that happen who was this guy
turns out we installed as the president
of afghanistan a professor from johns
hopkins
who like is the last person i mean it
just tells you everything about our
ruling class which is they only
talk to
believe trust promote people exactly
like them if you are
i don't think you speak dario or pashto
i'm assuming but if i said dave rubin
your job is to pick a leader of
afghanistan you'd probably pick
some pretty tough poshtune warlord type
who could make the provinces obey if you
wanted a central government right he
probably wouldn't have gone to john
hopkins how about that right
so then it turns out that this guy's dog
he's got two kids both of the american
passports one is a and i'm quoting
visual artist in brooklyn
and the other was the staff for pete
buddha judge's presidential campaign and
you're like wait a second afghanistan
the poorest country in the world on the
other side you know south asia other
side of the globe we pick a leader who
is exactly
like our leaders and that's how you know
that it's all about narcissism like it's
only about self-love self-worship like
these people are incompetent
because they're narcissists like they
can't imagine that anybody but a johns
hopkins professor of some like totally
douchey discipline too like social
science
he's not even like a math professor he's
not even a real professor and you made
him president of afghanistan because i
think it was i think it was lesbian
dance theory i'll have to i'll
so but but how bad do you i mean
like how bad do you think this will be i
mean it seems to me this is almost the
type of thing if we had an honest media
that could actually topple an
administration like this this seems like
and now the phone call where biden
basically was in advance trying to cover
the whole thing up about how bad things
had gotten there like this seems
extraordinarily awful
yeah i mean i i think it's one of those
moments and there are you know usually
things change incrementally in a way
that's only barely perceptible and you
wake up and everything's different you
know 2015 the middle class became the
minority of the american population no
one really noticed
six years later it's like pretty obvious
okay that we live in brazil
this is one of those rare moments where
the pivot point is like right in your
face it's crisp it's dramatic it's on
television like you know that nothing
will be the same after this you're just
not exactly sure in what way it'll be
different but the obvious the obvious
effects of course were just a radical
diminishment of american power you know
it's pretty clear the united states
can't actually enforce its will even on
this stone each country
it can't make anybody do what it wants
them to do it won't protect people it
says it will protect a kid and protect
its own citizens because it doesn't even
try
the people in charge are dumb they don't
know they're dumb they have no actual
skills they're totally unaware of that
like it's just it's ripped the mask off
and
i i'm not personally smart enough to
figure out all the ramifications of this
but they are absolutely profound and
you're going to see an acceleration of
trends already in progress which is like
none of the 340 million people who live
here really think that people in charge
have any clue what they're doing nobody
really believes the system is real
nobody actually thinks we live in a
representative democracy nobody really
believes in american empire like it just
makes everybody totally cynical
totally atomized
there is no kind of
center of gravity in america like what
it
right this is bad man i think it's
really really bad is that the most
dangerous place that a country can be
that it only works if we believe that it
works and we sort of it feels like we're
in the show must go on version of
democracy like yes like oh it's just got
to go on because it's got to go on even
though the president probably has
dementia nobody's listening to anybody
we're we're unearthing and upending
everything we ever believed in but we
got to keep the show going
but everything works that way i mean
everything i mean there's a huge corpus
of literature on you know the effective
attitude on health
you know there are there are cases not a
few many cases that are documented in
the medical literature of people who got
better because they like decided to
so like yeah you know mind over matter
that's a real thing how you feel about
something and the opposite is also true
anxiety can give you cancer like
terminal cancer so how you feel about
something
determines what that thing is and in in
the case of like a huge
incredibly complex project like running
a country this big
it's determinative it makes all the
difference like if people believe in and
it works if they don't it doesn't
and i'm just amazed there are a lot of
reasons why no one believes in the
system anymore but i'm just amazed by
the recklessness of a ruling class that
sets out intentionally to destroy say
patriotism
and then what do you replace it with
right we haven't replaced it with
anything so like we kneel for the anthem
okay what's your idea
you know we don't have a racial majority
a religious majority increasingly not
even a meaningful linguistic majority
like what is it that
holds the country together what do we
all have in common you know countries
don't hang together by accident
you know centrifugal force is a is a
physics principle like it breaks apart
unless there's a reason for it to hold
together period
so what's ours
and the idea they would systematically
go through and like destroy the the last
remaining
connective tissue between
hundreds of millions of americans
professional sports well we're all into
football not anymore anymore that's a
political category now you know we're
all we all believe in the military not
anymore they're lecturing us about white
rage oh [ __ ] i'm white i guess i'm
excluded from this i mean like well who
thought of this this is the single
craziest thing our ruling class has done
has been thematic
and the theme is destroy the connection
between americans if you're looking for
more honest and thoughtful conversations
about the media instead of non-stop
yelling check out our media playlist and
if you want to watch full interviews on
a variety of topics check out the full
episode playlist they're both right over
here and to get notified of all future
videos be sure to subscribe and click
the notification bell